[Musique]
les entreprises ne risquait pas de
couler le gouvernement a fait un choix
donc il a ouvert le chômage temporaire à
toutes les entreprises même les
entreprises qui auraient pu
supporter le conserver leurs salariés
durant cette période est grosso modo
c'est pareil pour tout j'aime bien sûr
que ce soit le 10 milliards de baisses
du de taxer la production la baisse de
l'impôt sur les sociétés qui part de 34
23 à 25% pour les entreprises tout ça
est donné sans le moindre contrôle sans
condition en matière au maintien
d'emplois sans condition en matière de
lutte pour le changement climatique
le but de ces entreprises du cac 40 de
ces entreprises multinationales c'est
avant tout de maximiser le profit des
actionnaires et donc ça veut dire
obligatoirement essayer de licenciés en
france et pourra les produire moins cher
dans les pays à bas salaires c'est la
logique même du capitalisme
financier mondialisé
les dirigeants des grandes entreprises
ne sont pas des philanthropes ainsi
peuvent effectivement faire des
économies au prix d actionner at-il de
faux
[Musique]